the legacy of pirates of the caribbean
star johnny depp has been put on full
display this week during the ongoing
defamation trial against his ex-wife
amber heard who is accused of tarnishing
it with alleged claims of spousal abuse
with each new day of testimony the
public has learned more and more about
depp's life in the limelight and behind
the scenes including a few sad truths
about his career and future after taking
the stand depp said have heard's
allegations it just didn't need to go
in that direction on april 20th the
depth described how heard's allegations
had in the long run it cost him
everything this referenced the fact that
the actor wound up losing his roles in
both the fantastic beasts and pirates of
the caribbean film franchises as a
result of the abuse scandal at one point
during wednesday's testimony depp was
asked about some claims he made in the
past in regard to disney and whether
he'd ever be willing to work with the
media giant again in the future his
answer will leave many pirates fans and
fans of captain jack in particular
feeling a little heartbroken yes it
seems that the real world legal battles
between amber heard and johnny depp have
meant that depp's days of playing
captain jack sparrow for disney have
finally come to an end the actor
confirmed during his testimony on
wednesday that there is no way he could
ever work for the mickey mouse company
again not even for hundreds of millions
of dollars when attorney ben ruttenborn
asked if 300 million dollars wouldn't be
enough to convince depp to reprice his
role as captain jack the actor responded
in the affirmative over the course of
herd's defamation trial depp's legal
team has attempted to prove that she
caused harm to his reputation and career
by making abuse claims in a december
2018 washington post article which
didn't identify depp by name heard's
lawyers have been trying to show that
any damage cause was not a result of the
article but instead came before the
op-ed was published they argued
wednesday that depp's disdain for disney
had stemmed from a reported falling outs
that the two parties had in october 2018
with an article from the daily mail at
the time claiming depp was quote out as
jack sparrow the notion that depp would
never return to the role not even for
300 million dollars came from the
statements that the actor made in his
deposition should he win deb is seeking
50 million dollars in compensatory
damages and a punitive award of at least
350 000
johnny depp's time as captain jack
sparrow dates back to the launch of the
pirates of the caribbean franchise in
2003. pirates of the caribbean the curse
of the black pearl introduced to
moviegoers to the iconic character and
suffice to say he quickly became the
heart and soul of the series you are
without doubt the worst pirate i've ever
heard of
but you have heard of me for the next 14
years across four more films depp stuck
with the parts remaining a highlight
despite the ip's diminishing popularity
and financial viability so with him now
gone as rumblings of a sixth movie
persist what does the future hold for
pirates of the caribbean narratively
speaking the absence of captain jack
shouldn't be too difficult to work
around seeing as the next part of the
caribbean adventures will apparently be
reboots deadline reported as much in
2019 noting that ted elliott and craig
mazin were collaborating on a new story
for the franchise come mid-2020 birds of
prey writer christina hudson had signed
on to write a separate reboot with
margot robbie as the lead however in the
years since these news tidbits came to
light the next pirate's flicks seem to
have fallen into production limbo it may
have degraded somewhat over the years
but pirates of the caribbean remains one
of disney's most beloved film series
regardless of the quality or plot it
stands to reason that fans would come
out in droves to buy tickets to see more
installments although should such
features ever make their way to the big
screen it would be unwise to hold your
breath for a cameo by captain jack
sparrow if you were waiting for the
opportune moment
that was it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one